[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour une
nouvelle saison de mode d'emploi notre
magazine consacré à l'emploi et à la
formation professionnelle
la thématique de ce premier numéro la
création d'entreprise tout de suite le
sommaire tous les acteurs de la création
d'entreprise rassemblés au ski tube
c'est le principe du premier forum je
crée ma boîte organisé par saint quentin
en yvelines mardi 24 septembre
objectif conseiller accompagner les
entrepreneurs première démarche premier
rendez vous identifier les acteurs tv 78
et glisser dans la peau d'un créateur
d'entreprise nous avons rencontré céline
leroux responsable relations entreprises
au ski tubes pour obtenir les premières
clés de notre projet enfin nous recevons
sur notre plateau olivier devenu le pdg
de lingway custodia cette entreprise il
y monte elle vient de lever plus d'un
million d'euros une société créée en
2011 nous reviendrons sur son histoire
télé 60,18 se lance dans la création
d'entreprise c'est une fiction bien sûr
mais nous avons comme projet de créer un
commerce nous avons obtenu un premier
rendez vous aux cubes dans nos proches
notre projet de création d'une société
les premières démarches les premiers
conseils regarder ce document les images
sont signés rodolphe blondel et patrick
jacques de dixmude tv 78e glisse
aujourd'hui dans la peau d'un créateur
d'entreprise nous avons comme projet de
monter un commerce
direction le ski cul pour notre premier
rendez vous
[Musique]
et nous voilà arrivés au ski club c'est
ici que nous avons notre premier rendez
vous dans notre étape de création
d'entreprise ici on va obtenir des
conseils et découvrir les différentes
étapes de la création de notre projet
suivez moi on y va
[Musique]
via vos skis merci de m'accueillir donc
comme convenu comme je vous ai contacté
j'ai un projet d'ouvrir un commerce donc
de créer une entreprise et et je voulais
avoir les premiers renseignements les
les étapes disons pour créer son
entreprise
d'accord ok alors il ya quatre grandes
étapes dans la création d'entreprise
donc la première étape c'est
l'adéquation aux porteurs de projets
projet donc c'est à dire ça va permettre
de voir si votre projet est en cohérence
avec vos motivations votre personnalité
et la réglementation si on a eu la
deuxième étape c'est la partie étude de
marché donc là vous allez analyser la
clientèle la concurrence votre
environnement afin de voir si votre
activité allait potentiellement viable
ou pas
la troisième étape ça va être la partie
financière donc là on a monté un
prévisionnel financier notamment le plan
de financement voilà qu'est ce que vous
j'ai besoin pour démarrer mon activité
comme enjeu le finance et puis la partie
rentabilité le chiffre d'affaires que je
vais faire don combien je vais vendre de
t-shirts combien ils vont coûter
et puis bah qu'est ce que j'ai à payer
tous les mois mon loyer etc
donc ça nous permet de voir si le projet
est faisable d'un côté et rentable de
l'autre la quatrième étape c'est
l'aspect juridique
donc c'est de voir quel statut juridique
et le plus adaptée à votre projet or
nous savons que c'est un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui pour les créateurs
d'entreprises par rapport aux banques
notamment
vous parlez de la deuxième étape le
financement comment nous pouvons
financer notre création d'entreprise
notre notre commerce pour pour commencer
notre activité
bien sûr donc il existe différentes
aides pour pour augmenter vos fonds
propres donc par exemple ici on fait
partie d'un réseau qui s'appelle le
réseau initiative qui fait du prêt
d'honneur qui permettra de compléter vos
fonds propres donc c'est un prêt
d'honneur qui peut aller de 5 à 25 mille
euros et puis derrière
généralement il ya les banques
classiquement qui complète et qui sont
là j'ai rarement pour financer tout ce
qui est plutôt matériel investissement
de démarrage pour son activité
maintenant qu'on a la vision globale je
me fais un peu une idée sur les étapes
qui m'attendent qu'est ce que je fais
dès demain d'accord déjà dès demain va
falloir écrire votre projet donc qui
vous
est vos motivations et puis commencer à
regarder par rapport à votre projet ce
que vous souhaitez vendre s'il ya un
marché s'il ya une clientèle sur saint
quentin
si vous souhaitez vous installer en tout
cas sur saint quentin qui sont déjà les
concurrents qui déjà installés pour voir
voilà comment vous allez vous
positionner par rapport à eux
et puis dans un deuxième temps vous
allez d'identifier comme ça si on est
sur un local gratien locale une zone de
chalandise donc peut-être un lieu ce
qu'on va s'installer en centre-ville
est ce qu'on va s'installer en
e-commerce et du coup plus tôt peut-être
dans une pépinière d'entreprise voilà
selon les possibilités et je dirais
l'analyse de votre étude de marché vous
allez pouvoir identifier ce que vous
allez faire qui va permettre derrière de
déboucher sur les premières prévisions
financières de votre projet je sais que
vous êtes ma ma porte d'entrée le ski
club sera ma porte d'entrée pour la
création de mon entreprise
est-ce que je peux m'adresser à d'autres
acteurs bien sûr donc au sein du ski qu
on a un réseau de partenaires qui vient
régulièrement notamment dans le cadre du
réseau entrepreneurs hashtag leader
porté par la région
on a une possibilité en face d'un de se
faire accompagner pour le montage du
business plan notamment donc sur les
quatre étapes que je vous ai cités c'est
la chambre de commerce la chambre de
métiers et le réseau bg e
voilà qui sont les trois acteurs du
territoire à intervenir bon je pense que
j'ai suffisamment d'informations pour ce
premier rendez vous en tout cas on peut
prévoir peut-être un autre entretien on
pourra bien sûr hein qu'est ce qu'on
pourra faire à ce moment-là barreaux
pour avoir la partie au moment où vous
aurez commencé à écrire votre projet on
va pouvoir avancer et puis voir au fur
et à mesure un peu un plan d'étape un
plan d'action sur les études de marché
ou est-ce que vous en êtes un bon c'est
sur le prévisionnel ou pas au pao pao
fonction de votre avancement sélune
euros merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci pour votre accueil bas derrière je
vais vous raccompagner merci
et pour toute information sur la
création d'entreprise vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site du ski cube qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
l'événement je crée ma boîte un forum
sur la création et la reprise
d'entreprise organisé mardi 24 septembre
à saint quentin en yvelines
toute la journée plusieurs partenaires
du ski cubes ont apporté des réponses
aux autres aux autres preneurs les
images de rodolphe blondel
accompagnement financement expertise
réseau et immobilier d'entreprise les
acteurs de la création d'entreprise au
forum je crée ma boîte
un événement organisé par saint quentin
en yvelines et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines
objectif conseiller et orienter les
entrepreneurs dans leurs démarches de
création
la plupart du temps les porteurs de
projets viennent en disant j'ai une idée
je veux savoir la meilleure forme
juridique kim qui me convient
et les aides que je peux avoir donc mon
rôle c'est dans un premier temps c'est
dire c'est bien de vous poser ces
questions-là
mais ce n'est pas que ça avant il faut
poser votre projet par écrit pour savoir
si votre projet est bien parmi les
visiteurs cédric leroy son projet créer
une société de conseil dans le domaine
du sport avec pour cible le marché
indien j'étais un petit peu perdues pour
être tout à fait franc avec vous il ya
énormément de statut de société qui
existe j'ai pris des renseignements un
petit peu sur internet mais je me suis
vite rendu compte qu'il y avait une
limite à tout ça et que c'était
important de pouvoir échanger avec des
personnes physiques et a pris justement
qui avait un service international au
niveau de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie sauf que je ne savais pas du
tout donc j'ai fait une prise de rendez
vous et ils m'accompagnent auront
ensuite sur justement le choix de
mon statut d'entreprise de son côté
sybille capelle veut développer une
plateforme de recrutement
une démarche après plusieurs années
passées en entreprise demandeurs
d'emploi elles se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat un réseau qui est très
très bien ficelé et qui aide grandement
les créateurs d'entreprise dd l'embryon
d'idées donc c'est plutôt sympa la
création d'entreprise un enjeu
stratégique pour saint quentin en
yvelines à la fois sur le volet
économique et sociale c'est d'abord
souvent des emplois pour ceux qui créent
leur entreprise qui décide entre
guillemets de se mettre à leur compte et
puis ça permet de créer aussi de
nouveaux emplois vous donne un seul
chiffre parmi les entreprises que nous
accompagnons moins que nous accompagnons
pardon ici à saint quentin en yvelines
80% d'entre elles créent au bout de deux
ans plus de deux emplois au premier
trimestre 2010 9 plus de 5200
entreprises ont été créées dans les
yvelines et on accueille olivier
debeugny sur notre plateau bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le fondateur et pdg de
lingway custodia une entreprise créée en
2011 engagé dans la fine tech donc la
finance technologique
un mot sur votre activité vous traduisez
automatiquement des documents financiers
grâce à une intelligence artificielle
c'est bien ça en fait on crée ce qu'on
appelle des moteurs de traduction
automatique donc tout le monde connaît
de grands nombres quand on veut traduire
un menu de restaurants ou autres sur le
net
nous on fait la même chose sauf que
c'est ils tracent spécialisé façon être
très pertinent par types de documents
dans le secteur financier ont des livres
ça à nos clients qui sont tous des
banques et des institutions financières
votre actualité vous venez de lever 1
million d'euros pour redévelopper votre
activité à quoi vont servir ces fonds
justement on a levé un peu plus d'un
million d'euros en effet récemment
en vue de faire un développement
commercial fort à l'international
d'ouvrir notre première filiale à
l'étranger
tout en continuant à renforcer notre
base technique ici à 50 ans et demi vous
avez été créés en 2011
aujourd'hui 2019 vous arrivez à lever 1
million entre temps vous avez aussi
lever d'autres fonds comme on explique
cette réussite voilà alors depuis notre
création on a levé au 2 millions 4 2 4
millions d'euros à peu près donc ça se
fait pas comme ça d'un seul coup
l'histoire d'une entreprise c'est
toujours peut toujours un peu parfois
être longue que ce qu'on pense la
société a comme vous l'avait dit et
écrit en 2011
l'idée de la boîte remonte à 2008 la
commercialisation s'est faite fin 2014
on a commencé à vraiment survivre
commercialement en 2010 est on
aujourd'hui en 2019
voilà donc justement on est sur une
thématique de la création d'entreprise
aujourd'hui une réussite à saint quentin
en yvelines
comment vous vous êtes lancé vous avez
dit que ça a commencé en 2008 comment
vous avez fait pour vous lancer moi j'ai
le profil en fait des entrepreneurs qui
ont une carrière dans le monde corporate
qui ont toujours baigné dans mon
corporate et qui ont toujours eu la lie
des trains qui ont toujours été à la
recherche d'une idée business on se
disant bon le jour où je vais atteindre
la quarantaine j'aimerais bien monter ma
boîte et et préparer sa voix je suis
dans cette dans cette sorte de catégorie
là même si on n'aime pas mettre les gens
en catégorie maison que du coup j'ai eu
un certain confort disons pour me
préparer et pour avoir le temps de bien
lancer sa seulement c'est pas facile de
passer de l'univers 'corporate' on a
passé quasiment vingt ans à l'univers de
l'entrepreneuriat où on se retrouve
exactement exactement il ya des tas de
choses en fait qu il faut d apprendre qu
on a appris avant et prendre d'autres
réflexes donc les premières années sont
souvent une année d'adaptation des
années d'adaptation assez forte pour
cette raison là donc vous n'avez pas
tout de suite quitter votre poste au
sein de l'entreprise ou du groupe dans
lequel vous étiez vous avez d'abord mûri
le projet avant de quitter votre poste
de salarié et de vous lancer et j'ai
même bénéficié de deux choses qui sont
assez fantastique en france qui
s'appelle par exemple congé sabbatique
partiel pour création d'entreprise
donc ça c'est un des mécanismes que j'ai
utilisé
pour commencer à constituer la société
et avancer progressivement parce qu'on a
un contenu technologique assez fort avec
du diplôme ning et c'est donc une
technologie à acquérir et donc toute une
paire de r&d développement avant de
pouvoir se lancer commercialement par
contre quand on se lance commercialement
là il faut il faut y aller à fond et
voilà on peut pas non plus avoir
plusieurs jobs il faut être à fond dans
le dans le business c'est donc bien
prévoir tout ça on arrive bientôt au
terme de cet entretien un dernier mot
c'est les conseils que vous pourriez
donner aux entrepreneurs qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui il faut persévérer
on rencontre beaucoup de difficultés et
en fait ce qui arrive ce dont on parle
ce sont ceux qui ont continué à force on
se prend des claques mais sont des
claques avoir regardé dans le sens
positif du terme et qui permettent
d'apprendre beaucoup et d'avancer
d'avancé droit et vous vous avez
persévéré puisque vous en remettre à la
septième huitième année de votre
histoire une histoire qui a commencé
donc à paris qui c'est qui est venu
s'installer aussi ensuite à saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur notre
plateau olivier de boeny merci le pdg et
fondateur de lingua custodia sur tv 78
et pour conclure ce premier numéro une
citation de l'ancien président de la
république jacques chirac décédé jeudi
26 septembre un extrait d'un discours
prononcé aux états généraux des jeunes
entrepreneurs européens en novembre 1999
au camp lorsqu'il était président de la
république
si la création d'entreprise est une
aventure personnelle et individuelle
c'est aussi la sphère de la société
toute entière car ces bénéfices ont
collectif la création d'entreprises est
en effet la clé de la croissance et de
l'emploi
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]